bom antes pensar eu queria fazer uma
denúncia porque eu tava que aconteceu
quando já que antes de ele entrar e nós
combinamos que ele assumiria fazer uma
leque ele sobre fases
fica complicado agora
bom eu puder das idéias
o título da minha apresentação é uma
pergunta vamos do palanca
pra quem não sabe o palanque um bairro
de luanda da parte suburbana perceber os
sinais dizem os sinais da infância aqui
quando só a minha história quando era
muito pequenina continua a série a ainda
é uma criança muito inquieta
sempre gostei de pintar sempre gostei de
trocar isso faz do lugar
estava sempre pra se trocava sofás
mudava a posição dos móveis
enfim tenha sempre algo criativo se
fosse assim dizer naquela altura para
fazer mas o meu sonho desde pequenina
sempre foi ser médica
nunca vi ninguém ser nada artístico vice
lá a trabalhar logo tem a ver quadro
sempre o cncs médica sonho esse que foi
alimentado pelo grande orgulho de meus
pais entre então se eu fosse médica mas
isso acaba frontera em 2004 eu mudo para
buenos aires
vou pra usar estudar medicina chegou em
bolas aéreas deslumbrada com a cidade e
tudo mais
começa a estudar medicina e dois anos e
meio depois começar a estudar medicina
eu fui obrigada a deixar a carreira de
medicina porque tem um problema da
energia e não suportava as aulas da
produção dos filmes do laboratório foi
um momento extremamente complicado para
mim era uma menina único sonho pinha e
que foi alimentado em sentir tenha sido
alimentada era ser médica
então eu vi ano com dois anos e meio de
investimento dos pais para universidades
e praticamente 100
sem saber o que fazer sem saber para
onde ir sem saber todos que profissão
seguir sem contar com a pressão dos meus
pais faziam também não vai ser médica
mas agora quer fazer esse bom eu fiquei
realmente perdida
atendendo processa o que eu sentia desde
criança ouve a surfar ao quanto uma vez
ao acordar de manhã disse hoje eu vou
mudar a posição dos móveis no quarto
então pega tanto que tenho no meu quarto
muda a posição mas como ela tinha hoje
tem 18 e 53 naquela altura havia até um
metro e vinte mais ou menos cai parte
quando a minha mais chega à casa de uma
bruta sua menina ter vida com esse
tamanho ou uma história desse tamanho
enfim a minha vida mudou ali quando
aquela história se partiu mas eu não
sabia não percebia que ele queria dizer
era bom o belo dia uma tia minha muito
com um psicólogo psicanalista
eu estava com muitas dúvidas depois da
medicina não sabia o que fazer
chego lá faça o exame psicotécnico
começa a fazer o exame psicotécnico e e
depois terminar
ela olha pra mim isso é muito notória a
sua vocação e eu espantada será notória
ficam até agora muitos vão descobrir
ela diz me tu és um artista eu olho pra
ela o bebê só aqui da psicologia ficar
lá é né ea bom sair mais confundida do
que entrei porque na verdade não percebi
que ela não queria dizer com aquilo que
era uma artista a importância dos sinais
é assim e depois disso ela ter dito isso
eu disse bom se ela quer dizer que uma
pista com alguma coisa ela quer dizer
com isso né dá algum lugar ela tirou que
eu sou uma artista
eu sempre gostei do roupa de criar e
pintar e desenhar sapatos
enfim tudo o que tivesse a ver com
indumentária liga o meu pai pai já
encontrei a minha vocação quero ser o
design do documentário no país nem
pensar
minha filha que é ser médica não vai vir
a costureira
isso não existe aqui na banda isso
costureira é assim eu vou fazer um
investimento quando chegamos aqui neste
momento em que tentava por nuno a cair
de costureira estação número 2 não podia
ser design indumentária mas continua a
pensar naquilo kaká psicóloga tinha dito
um artista num belo dia atua caminhar
pelas ruas urbanas ice vejo um anúncio
onde fala sobre o workshop a dar uma
universidade sobre entre design futebol
também gosto de imóveis para tem muitos
móveis não vi muitos móveis
vamos lá ver o que o estado começa a
fazer workshop do mês
fiquei apaixonada pelo clube saiu daí
inscreva na universidade cinco anos de
faculdade na faculdade e arquitetura
entre o design e hoje foi uma entre o
design quando refiro hoje a importância
dos sinais
eu acho que é assim a vida é feita de
grandes encontros foi na universidade
onde eu pude ter o meu grande encontro
com a arte
eu quando era menina eu sentia coisas
que não podia explicar não sabia que se
tratava não sabia sequer o porque que eu
não via tantos móveis e porque eu quero
que ela está
mas foi aí que eu ganhei ferramentas
para poder entender o que significa o
meu grande enquanto quarta
então esta enquanto o quarto perceber
dão as ferramentas que eu perceber eu
fiz design
existem duas vertentes o designer
o pedro é design e muito bem falou
nós temos que responder lhe responder às
necessidades do consumidor
temos que fazer um produto ou temos de
fazer é produzir em design de produto
faz produtos quem faz entre os fãs entre
outros quem faz roupa tem que fazer
roupas nós temos que fazer algo que
responda às necessidades do consumidor
mas um design é um artista qualidade
quando estudaram assim não queria ser a
cirurgia plástica
uma das coisas que eu disse a psicóloga
ela disse olha tem muito a ver com o
fato do exército cirurgia plástica
então o que acontece um designer quando
é designer e artista tem que despir
a roupa designer que aquela roupa do que
tem que ajudar um consumidor que teve
tempo de tirar a roupa do artista tem
que olhar para além do que se pode ver
quando eu falo de ferramentas
no meu caso essas ferramentas não foram
dadas na universidade porque
simplesmente é uma das profissões que eu
acho que ainda não temos muito
eu tive que aprender a dominar estes
dois lados o lado do artista se é que
posso considerar um artista e um lado do
designer então o design tem que
responder às necessidades do consumidor
mas o design o design é um poderoso
instrumento para agregar valor aos
produtos
no design existe o conceito do que a
forma cega função mas o artista os
sentimentos como matéria prima
um artista é movido por emoções este
projecto foi um projeto que eu fiz na
universidade na altura fiz com uma
grande amiga minha
uma estudante de designer também nós
vamos fazer um projeto para o município
chamava-se tigre era pequenos participar
do concurso e quem tivesse o melhor
projeto e as for o projeto e quem sabe
até podia fazer o projeto nós como
designers tínhamos a ferramenta nós
tínhamos eram para um estande
institucional para aquela aquela região
e nós sabíamos que nós queremos fazer é
instalar institucional daquela região
tínhamos o objeto temos o que íamos
representar ali mas não tenha uma
proposta porque era um concurso então
temos que pôr o melhor do nosso aliviam
disco por enfim assim mas as idéias mais
loucas ou não conseguimos fazer então um
belo dia para minha amiga de goya vamos
até o lugar e vamos ver o que teve lugar
nos dá como matéria prima
jogamos em nós a distância mais ou menos
daqui até viana não sei eo município do
tigre tem água tem folhas e disse eu
disse olha vamos dar vamos fazer um
passeio de barco subindo de fumar
começamos a andar a olhar para tudo para
ver se alguma coisa não despertava se
dizer alguma coisa e de repente
as duas olhamos pra água e vimos o
reflexo das folhas na água
olhamos as duas uma para a outra e
estamos nessa nossa nacional os projetos
mas porque começamos o projeto daí o
nosso projecto nasceu do reflexo das
folhagens na água
daí nasce o nosso projeto neste momento
que nós olhamos as duas pra água e vimos
aquilo
nos despimos a roupa design filmes a
roupa da artista
usamos as nossas emoções para poder ver
o que realmente está por detrás do
designer
então naquele momento nós éramos
artistas não éramos mais design não
tínhamos tudo responder a nenhuma cidade
do consumidor queríamos criar e foi o
que aconteceu com esse projeto
resta um caminho do projeto e por
incrível que pareça ganhamos o projeto
aqui começa a grande problemática acho
que muita gente está a perguntar o que
irão palanca tem a ver com arte e tem a
ver com o fato de eu ter descoberto a
minha vocação acidentalmente
eu acho que tem tudo a ver na minha
forma de ver pensar é assim quem
normalmente trabalha com arte tem um
olho de frente das outras pessoas talvez
eu acho que todos nós somos potenciais
criadores mas temos formas diferentes de
observar o mundo porque que eu usei isso
vamos a palavra a pergunta pra essa
minha resposta é a mesma quando subiu
para falar de sexo
dão as costas em crer que o weldon ou
seja tem uma mensagem que tenha aquilo
lá embaixo a que dizia porque a cidade é
um cenário e quem a faz sol são os que a
fazem ser quando acorda de manhã vai
trabalhar eu sempre olhava passava pelo
palanque e olhava para aquilo eu via
eu vi é um é espetacular o que eu via
uma obra teatral por um lado houve uma
mulher com 60 metros de penteado na
paragem do estado sempre ali eu ficava
de lembrada do outro lado olhava uma
mulher nessas nossas irmãs do congo com
dois metros do que está nas etar vai
olhar
do outro lado houve uma senhora com uma
expressão no rosto com bala na cabeça
com a criança
olhava pro outro lado tem um homem
graças sapatos com o fato assim slu
naquele calor mesmo bem e eu disse uau a
arte saiu do museu
isso pra mim é a calhar é um pouco
atrevido de minha parte aqui pra mim art
mas eu até queria te dizer que o losango
anos somos grandes artistas conceituais
aquela mulher está aí e está com um pé
nas costas e está com bala na cabeça ela
faz por formas quando alan
ela anda ela movimenta se ela tem bala
na cabeça tem que equilibrar o balaio
tem que cuidar da criança criança chora
enfim sem querer implicitamente ela tá
fazer arte
quando falava dos sinais da infância
falou exatamente disso então até que
ponto nós os angolanos somos conscientes
de que somos artistas natos
tem uma frase que eu ponho aqui que eu
acho que é
acho que o motor essa frase essa frase
diz que as grandes obras de arte nascem
das emoções nos momentos do amor de
sofrimento e que nós como povo temos uma
história que nos leva a desenvolver
características especiais
é verdade a grande eu acho que há sim um
povo tem uma história específica
eu acho que os grandes da área
normalmente criaram quando estava em
situações quando muito sofrimento ou de
muita alegria
no nosso caso como popular não temos uma
história muito sofrida eu acho que isso
de certa forma têm um pacto como
sociedade nós não temos as ferramentas
para explorar efe
mas nós fizemos dar em quase tudo como
diziam já que não existe gás hoje hoje
foi foi brilhante que eu vim aqui porque
hoje foi aí que eu vi e só os angolanos
nós que estamos aqui temos ferramentas
mas outras pessoas não têm
quando eu próprio quando digo nós
lançamos artistas conceituais talvez um
grande atrevimento entrará em campo
porque é um campo um cadinho delicado
o que o artista conceitual flash o
artista conceitual sabendo que o
conceito que transmitiria não se importa
com o objeto mas se importa com atitude
mental que são objeto irá transmitir
essa cadeira é uma cadeira com o objeto
o artista conceitual artista pode chegar
aqui e dizer não isso é uma borboleta
porque eu quero que seja uma borboleta
como objeto a cadeira mas como eu sou a
pista arte diz que eu sou livro então
digo que sois uma borboleta
então eu digo será que nós lançamos
órbitas artistas conceptuais aí já entra
a grande controvérsia por dizer que não
porque nós não temos ferramentas
então vou voltar pra minha infância
queria fazer uma pergunta queria ter a
colaboração de todos
eu queria que os pais tivessem equipes
assim a moeda enquanto os pais têm aqui
paz mas muitos
porque eu faço essa pergunta quando eu
era pequena eu dei vários sinais com os
meus pais
muitos não era por acaso que eu ouvia
tanto faz
não foi por acaso que partiam há
instantes então eu quero dizer aos pais
e futuros pais com os vossos filhos dão
sinais todo o tempo do que querem ser e
do que querem fazer em sinais vão nos
ajudar a ver quando estamos em presença
do ano do artista incubado no caso podia
ser eu quero uma artista estava ali mas
partiam há instantes mas não percebia
porque é aquele menino que tem que
descobrir dos meninos que movem
instância e trocam sul faz do lugar
o artista consciente que é aquele caso
do paraquedas numa peça de teatro
alguém convidou deu certo foi annan eo
grande está consciente que pode ser por
exemplo onde atua
eu acredito quando já que desde que
conheceu sempre deu sinais alguma coisa
já que fez 16 engolir uma caneta se
partiu
não sei mas alguma coisa de gol já que
elisangela todo mundo de alguma forma dá
sinais quando era mais novo quando
pequeno o artista continua consciente
porque depois eu tenho um vídeo que vai
falar às pessoas vão falar em primeira
pessoa e vão perceber o porquê dessa
minha teoria do ato está consciente e
inconsciente
esse rapaz que está aqui chama jesus ele
é ator e ator argentino
eu tive o prazer de conhecer um grande
amigo meu e ela é daquelas pessoas que
respirar tem tudo que faz
não tem como mente não há outra outra
definição para ele porque ele respira
arte e fazer tudo que faz um belo dia
jesus liga pra mim e disse sheila
eu vou participar num filme que vai
falar sobre a vida de jesus cristo na
américa latina eu que bom que o um papel
muito importante muito bom mas para
jogar por aquele esmalte é um papel que
emocionou muito
eu não tinha percebido por que por que
não dizer aquilo
ele só eu vou te mandar umas fotografias
e portugueses o que é que tu viste
naquela fotografia
essas são as fotos do meu amigo jesus
caracterizado de jesus cristo
ele se chama jesus e vai fazer o papel
de jesus cristo
quando eu olhei para fotografias eu
disse seu primeiro livro o velho porque
é realmente houve uma o espetáculo
espetacular mas depois eu sentia disse
olha os dois o que eu senti
é o que se pode sentir quando um artista
consciente de que artista quando não é
isso e no qual não pode ser outra coisa
é artista e ponto final foi isso que eu
senti
eu senti uma emoção grande entrevista é
caracterizado de jesus cristo pode
chegar aqui alguém dizer ah mas o mérito
é do do que faz a maquiagem que assim
também
mas por outro lado essa mesma maquiagem
fosse feita em qualquer outra pessoa não
se encontre o efeito que talvez tenha
por trás dessa maquiagem existe um
grande ator dá vida essa maquiagem
então eu tenho um vídeo que tem pessoas
aqui que eu vou falar pra nós e que vão
dar o seu contributo vamos ver vamos ver
o vídeo
o piloto do mundo
gostei
apesar de ajudar emprego em perceba o
que eu gosto de viajar andarei apagar
incêndios
eu penso é muitas coisas
comecei com a astróloga porto vinho e
pressionar e achei que ele foi
fantástico
passei para psicóloga eu gostava de
falar com as pessoas e achava que era
essa a minha a minha força
vamos assim dizer depois quis muito
sério dançarina coreógrafa você mais
precisa ficar com este sonho durante
muito tempo eu estava fora e fui estudar
fora com uma bolsa e apesar do companhia
supostamente onde eles incentivam muita
criatividade individualismo
sempre fui com a pressão implícita um
adulto tinha que voltar com um diploma
que serviço para a instituição que não
conseguiu a bolsa então acabei por
deixando do lado dos meus sonhos
artísticos muito entretenimento não é da
bolsa tinha subido 1 litro momento eu
acho que tudo que eu sou capaz de fazer
não foi explorado e estiver sem descurar
estiver sido alimentado não somente por
mim mas por forças externas
eu acho que provavelmente eu não seria
quem eu sou hoje a liga dos
profissionais não é eu acho acredito
firmemente que não teria 8 e às vezes
claro button arrependimento neve sendo
em kano provavelmente não terão seis
instituições mas a batalha muito mais
feliz fazendo a boca sempre sonhei em
fazer coisas de tudo ligado à arte se
fosse assim dizer
bom eu fui daquelas crianças que sempre
sonhou em ser médico
estes formandos em medicina mas
infelizmente não consegui fazer
sou daquelas pessoas que está aqui nesta
cabo sem saber com porque tanto a
carreira de ator como modelo começaram
como brincadeiras infantis assim é eu
comecei como ator por causa de uma
brincadeira com as amigas fizeram comigo
e fui vales desportiva brincar mas
depois as coisas começaram a se
encaminhar mais sérias
isso tudo começou em 2003 eu passei só
vou pensar nisso como uma coisa boa uma
coisa negativa porque já há algum tempo
têm um cinto vai fazer as coisas bem
feitas
então não sei se seria uma coisa muito
mais se não tivesse caindo assim como
campo para queda de neve
o modelo mas talvez as coisas fossem
podemos encarar as coisas num plano
diferente mas nossa diz esta seria bom
se não o nome sonhada linha sempre foi
justamente por se une e movimento sempre
ninguém queria atuar
não não dá pra mim é um sonho não
proibiram ou comer merda nascia lo é tão
não tenha muito pressionado caminho e
guarda em curas porque aí por ele tome
maquinário e os sakala todos os
personagens que havia entre o minho
assim sepultado e sabugal lo
é era mim mundo molhado para mim é um
homem
sue lance do existência humana com os
outros humanos e contorno que o controlo
de uma glória para mim é vida e temos do
caminho
queremos agarrar no ar e continua
invicto e que o caminho e que
o alencar nã